hey this is presh talwalkar and you're
watching mind your decisions
here's a really fun problem from the
1995 mathematical olympiad in argentina
is it possible to write the 11 whole
numbers from 1985 to 1995 in some order
so that the 44 digit number you get is
prime
why or why not
provide a proof of your answer
thank leon from argentina for suggesting
this problem
can you figure it out
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for a
solution
so before i get to the solution i'll
admit there are many many puzzles that
i'm not able to solve by myself
this includes amazon's hanging cable
problem the hardest easy geometry
problem and many many more
but this problem i actually figured out
in my head and i got the insight in just
one minute
so before i get to the solution i want
to tell a supposed story about picasso
one day in the park a woman offered to
pay picasso for a portrait
he quickly drew a sketch and she replied
wow you captured my essence in just a
few strokes
how much do i owe you
picasso said
it cost
ten thousand dollars
stunned the woman said
how can it be so much you only took one
minute
picasso then replied no madam it took me
my entire life
so bringing this back to mind your
decisions people often ask me how long
does it take you to make a video
my answer is the time for an individual
video only measures the marginal effort
each video has actually taken me a
lifetime to make
the lesson is that solving problems is
like an art form you get better with
lifelong practice
some habits that improve my problem
solving skills are practicing my times
table as a child reading every math book
in my library for fun during summer
breaks and writing the best mental math
tricks it was in this book that i
reinforced the divisibility by 11 rule
which was the key principle to solving
this problem
so here's the solution
the number can never be prime it will
always be divisible by 11. to explain
why this is true let's review the
divisibility by 11 rule
this states that if the alternating sum
of digits from left to right is
divisible by 11 then the number is
divisible by 11.
the procedure is to take the first digit
then subtract the second then add the
third then subtract the fourth and so on
in other words you need to add up the
digits in the odd spots and then
subtract the digits in the even spots
so let's go over a few quick examples
77 will be 7 minus 7 which is 0.
0 is divisible by 11 so 77 is 2.
consider 243
the alternating sum is 2 minus 4 plus 3
which is equal to 1.
since 1 is not divisible by 11
243 is not divisible by 11.
what about a more complicated number
like 91 905
we first calculate the alternating sum
which is 22
and then we conclude that 22 is
divisible by 11 which means 91 905 is
also divisible by 11.
so how can we use this principle for our
current problem
well first let's write the 11 numbers in
descending order
we need to calculate the alternating sum
of this number
we'll do that by first calculating the
sum of all the black digits which is the
digits in the odd positions
i'll write it out in long form but this
simplifies to be the following
and this is an easy calculation and it's
equal to 105.
now let's calculate the sum of the blue
digits the digits in the even
positions i'll write it out in long form
and then we'll do a few calculations and
we'll simplify it and it will equal 149
so the alternating sum will be the sum
of the black digits minus the sum of the
blue digits and this will be equal to
negative 44.
since negative 44 is divisible by 11 the
entire number is
in fact
the alternating sum will be equal to
negative 44 it will be invariant no
matter how we arrange the 11 whole
numbers from 1985 to 1995.
so we've just shown that this particular
number is divisible by 11 but i'm going
to claim it'll be true no matter how we
arrange these 11 numbers
the reason is that the black digits will
always be in odd positions and the blue
digits will always be in the even
positions
so let's say we rearrange the numbers
like this
well the alternating sum is still going
to be the same because the black digits
are always in the odd positions and the
blue digits are always in the even
positions
here's a little bit more complicated
over rearrangement we're still going to
have the same alternating sum of
negative 44.
it'll be true no matter how we arrange
these 11 numbers
because each number has four digits no
matter how we rearrange them we're
always going to have the black digits in
odd positions and the blue digits in
even positions
therefore the alternating sum will
always be negative 44
and therefore the resulting number will
always be divisible by 11.
so now you know the method to solve this
problem
and the next time you see a similar
problem you might just be able to solve
it instantly in your head
but should someone try to diminish your
mental feet remind them you weren't born
with this ability it actually took you a
lifetime of learning to hone your
problem solving skills
thanks for watching these math videos
which are available for free on youtube
build confidence for students and
inspire mathematical discovery for
viewers around the world they have over
100 million views and the channel has
over 1 million subscribers
please subscribe for free to get the
newest videos and email me a puzzle or
math topic presh mindyourdecisions.com
if you so choose you can check out my
merchandise and my books which are
listed in the video description and you
can support me on patreon for exclusive
rewards thanks for watching and thanks
for your support